Okay, welcome to the DDPS
seminar everyone. Before we
introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and
logistics. First of all, please
mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions. If
you have questions, you're
welcome to unmute and ask.
Otherwise, please use the chat
room to post your questions so
that we can address them in q&a
session at the end. Second,
today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audiences, there are no
classify this question aloud.
And finally, the talk today will
be recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel. That's about
it. Now, let me introduce our
speaker today. honor to host the
Jianchao who is a Cardis Collins
professor at Northwestern
specializing in innovative
manufacturing process and
systems particularly in the
areas of deformation based
processes and laser additive
manufacturing manufacturing
processes. She's the founding
director of the University
Research Center on manufacturing
Science and Innovation at
Northwestern known as an MC
served as an Associate Vice
President for Research at
Northwestern from 2012 to 2021.
She has co authored over 250
journal articles 20 patents and
the several opinion opinion
articles. cow has been the
editor in chief of journal of
materials processing, processing
technology since 2018. And
Professor cow is an elected
member of the National Academy
of Engineering, a fellow
American Association for
Advancement of Science and many
other organizations. And she's,
she's the recipient of many
prestigious awards as well,
including ASME had political
applied mechanics or Word and
ASME Milton show Manufacturing
Research medal. She served as
the president of the SME North
American manufacturing of
Research Institute, Chair of
ASME manufacturing engineering
division and the program
director at the National Science
Foundation. So today, Professor
cow will talk about physics
based AI assisted design and
control in flexible
manufacturing. Please enjoy and
expect a wonderful talk. Now,
without further ado, let me pass
the baton to Professor cow by
asking one random question. As
usual, today's random question
is, what is your idea of the
perfect day?
Perfect days today?
Yeah, every day is the perfect
Yes, that's awesome. Okay,
great.
Thank you very much for the
invitation. And so, my goal of
this talk is to share some high
level of the activities of what
we do. So in our lab, we have
been, you know, looking at both
in numerical simulations as well
as developing innovative
manufacturing processes. So that
intersection is really
interesting. So what I'm the
goal is to share, as I said, the
you know, the high level
activities and hopefully to
derive some new in detail the
discussions later on. So, here's
the email address, which is the
best way to reach me and with
that, let me move forward. So,
the ultimate goal of our lab is
really looking starting from the
materials looking at the PSPP in
a process structure property
relationships, and the material
is a base for you know,
manufacturing processes right.
And then when we added in are
those innovative process and
machine designs, the reason that
we want to design all mache is a
bill of capability of say
imposing a new metrology system
so we can have the data that we
can analyze, knowing that the
details about how those data
were generated, right, as well
as being able to develop a new
processes, it's hard to do a
process development with a
specific instrumentation and
meanwhile, also to feed back to
the process to do the control.
And then the other part is that
design and design many times you
can have looking at just product
material and process design
Secretary The ultimate goal of
our lab as well as my
collaborators here at
Northwestern, as well as me
nationwide, is trying to also
think about CO design of these
different aspects. And find that
I, you know, very well is a
qualification or certification
that will be needed for this. So
overall, linking all these
together is a simulation and
data. So what we have been doing
also last year with my
colleague, Professor when can
live and, again, is to look at
the, how AI and mechanics work
together to drive the things
that I talked about earlier for
process design for process
modeling, and for process
control. So, what I would do is,
in this talk, I'm going to talk
about these three aspects. To
show how we do that using
additive metal additive
manufacturing, as example. As
well as some at the very end,
I'm going to show some flexible
sheet metal forming process,
which is really complementary
very well with metal additive.
So with that, too, you know,
what I want to show you this,
this is our home built, laser
additive mushy. And this is we
call it additive rapid
prototyping instrument RP. What
it does is a powder, Brom laser
additive process directed energy
deposition. And for this
particular one, you know, you
can see the environmental
chamber, living lasers, and
what's up here, actually, I have
a more detail the ones later on,
is this one. So, this one, we
have RP from the backside, we
also have four different, you
know, hoppers from Potter motion
maps, as well as two of those.
So we can deposit different
materials, right. So this is one
examples that you deposit, you
know, for different, Steel's
and, and you can also mix it
with that, the key questions
that we want to ask is, What
about other mechanical
properties that are generated
from that deposition. Certainly,
porosity is of the concern. And
what we did, by being close to
Argonne National Lab, we put the
DD system into argon, the high
density, high speed X ray
imaging of the DD. So what you
can see is that deposit right
here, deposit layer here, and
the X ray imaging weather and we
developed a high throughput, you
know, sample sample drum, as
well as the deposition, such
that we can get lots of data
changing the process parameter
to see what's happening. And
just a glance about you know,
the setup are gone. So, so it's
not curved that just because of
the picture is taken in the in
the panoramic view, right. But
the key thing is, you know, if
you look at the powder is
flowing down, and this is the
male pool, and many people have
been doing this for the powder
bed for the DD, we were among
the very first group actually
doing that. So, but the key
thing in there so the we did a
lot of analysis of this for this
particular group, what I want to
say is, the key thing that
didn't notice is also the male
pool dynamics right male pool is
important in terms of how the
porosity is generated inside the
inside the belt, and
specifically we find out for our
particular application with a DD
is because you're carrying a lot
of gas actually into the male
pool. So the male put depths in
addition to typically Paderborn
people looking at the width and
the length. So, for the the the
depths is actually equally
important. So, because of that,
you know, investigation,
therefore, from the numerical
point of view as well as from
the practical point of view, we
say okay, how can we control the
MailPoet depth during the
buildup? So the way that we do
it is, if you look at our
experimental setup, you can look
at the I find that the width and
the length right, but the depths
is information is not that
visible, but numerical
simulation can. So we develop
our own in house new numerical
simulation code called gamma.
And, and based on this, this is
a thermal
summit some thermal thermal code
basically. And you can you can
see that based on the
temperature, you can find out
what is a map with depth. What's
new here is in the simulation,
we use the MailPoet depths as
our target objective function,
and the build up the closed loop
control and change the input
which is a laser power in the
simulation. So, as a result, the
opposite of this is using one
simulation, the output is a
laser power history, such that
you can control the MailPoet
depths, wherever you are, right.
So, this method is much more
general in the sense in terms of
the geometry, or material
property or material types that
you're doing. And, because of
this, you know, what we did,
here's a quick glance about the
FTM code gamma. And as it here's
a governing equation, which is
pretty standard. And the the key
part for our particular
application is we need the speed
in order to do this cross loop
control to generate the laser
power. So, it's being
implemented with Parsa and and Q
pi is used for GPU acceleration.
So that we can do this very,
very good. And you can see that
you know, if you have the
constant laser power moving
forward, as you build up the
heat got accumulated, therefore,
the MailPoet depth is also
getting to be higher and higher,
but with the the constant
control the ones that laser
power, so, domain is changing as
decreasing as you could imagine,
and for the Melco depths is very
well controlled. So, we
implement this to our
experiments RP instrument, and
you can see also, you know, the
the heat, the colorization kind
of index about you know, how
good is heat accumulation, and
also you can use our camera from
the side to also indicate that
what's interesting is also
looking at properties right. So,
what we did is particularly to
see if the goal is whether you
can have location specific
control, so, we build up a box
and one side of the box has a
target male put that as a two
millimeter the other side that's
a 1.4 millimeter different
depth, we know that the depth is
different thermal history will
be different or some material
property will be different
right. So, and and that's
basically using the simulation
two I mentioned earlier to build
up the laser laser history and
we build the box and this is a
and b and once from the outside
the geometry you know, they look
pretty similar, but so, we cut
the tensile specimen from A and
B and then you pull it in so,
the stress strain curve, the
material behavior for a and b
are very different as you can
see, right. So, this is
interesting in the way because
sometimes many times we do
component design and sometimes
you want a different
microstructure at different
locations to get to the
properties you want for you
know, creep resistance for
strength, you have different
design. So, this gives you a way
to say you know, using the
additive manufacturing you can
actually put the different
properties is the as you need
it. One thing also interesting
from this one is that
particularly if you are a
material scientist, you know,
you look at this curve, you say
okay, a I have a deeper male
pool, which means you know, I
will have a slower cooling rate
and which means potentially, I
may have you know, a larger grid
size and therefore, you know, a
should be lower than B. So, why
this A is higher than B, you
know, so, we specifically
actually make sure that we got
the specimen at the right
location, what the interesting
came out is that the additive
you know, so what we did hear
they say we just build up the
wall and cut mini specimens at
these different portion of the
wall. And we also use our camera
to record the time history at
different points, and then just
purely using the data driven
approach to see, you know, what
is the significance of those
time thermal history that will
influence the properties, the
tensile properties right here.
So, we've done quite a lot of
different you know, checking out
different machine learning tool,
and this random forest actually
comes out to be pretty
interesting. So, what it does is
we put every 50 degree in terms
of the time you spend in that 50
degree interval, and then
correlate to the strengths say
tensile strength of the
material, and this plot shows
the, you know, relevance
importance. So, what's
interesting for impurities data
driven was it has two different
temperature regions has the most
effect in terms of the property.
And the first one, if you look
at this, the first one is very
much related to the measure the
liquidus to solidus temperature.
So basically, solidification
rate, and this is what we were
trying to control, right, if
we're not controlling the
MailPoet depth, and, and this is
a direct control indication of
that, but the second part is
equally important in this is
actually very much corresponding
to the standard heat treatment
temperature. So, what this tells
us is that the final property
that we are getting is a
combination of how you submit
the fire as well as additional
heating time that you have this
material point is experiencing,
right? So if you do that, you
know, you can come up with just
a fitting function right here.
And we use those walls you know,
we actually fit it and it's kind
of very interesting to see also
microstructure wise it fits this
kind of conclusion, one thing is
about the spacing which is
basically the other one that he
trimmer is also about these
additional Delta phase generated
that cut to the Britto lover
phases, and they're helped to
strengthen the material
properties right. So, from here,
what we are saying is okay, we
can't just do multiple control,
we actually need to control the
thermal history and thermal
history is very challenging
things to control right? Because
it's a highly dimensional
temporal and spatial design. So,
the way that we do it we say
okay, if we want to control
thermal history, the local
location specific control that
in the previous approach is not
going to be enough. So, the way
that we do it, we use the so
called differentiable
simulation. And basically we
rewrite our Gamma code in using
the differentiable simulation,
which is basically we use the
deep learning library for this
particular ratio, particular
application, we use the Tai Chi
one, but also in another one
that we are doing right now we
use Jack's which is developed by
Google basically, in those
libraries that we got with a
with a EES or tai chi or jacks,
it has it has the graph
representation about this
partial differentiable
simulation, right, partial
differential equation and use a
graph what it can do is it can
give you the gradient
information for free where you
are doing the forward analysis.
So it's automatic
differentiation provided by
those libraries and help us to
compute basically this Cobian
that you know, traditionally you
have to do it by yourself. So so
it's a gradient based continuous
optimization and people have
been used using differentiable
simulation for robotics path
planning, as well as you know,
this is becoming really popular
these days to also look at the
the fluids, you know, heat
transfer as we have it right
here. So, for us, you know, this
is what I mentioned earlier,
right? We use these tools to To
develop the another tool that
for our manufacturing process
design, so, what it does it can
come on the physics space the
simulation, and then what we do
is we represent the laser power
using a neural network. And here
you can think about these are
all partial differential
equations, in which you can put
everything together under a
global optimization framework.
And with that, what we can say
is if I want to have specific
thermal history, I can use the
you know, run this overall
simulations and get that what
you want. So, the key idea is,
we represent the laser power as
a time series and go through the
FTM simulation which is
differentiable, get the thermal
history, and then we do the
optimization. So, for example,
with this thin wall, and
multiple points, if the blue is
what we want, and we feeding to
the Adam atomization to to
basically framework and then
create the laser power as this
red line. Versus if it's
constant, it's a green you know,
so, as you can see the green the
thermal response from different
points are very different. So,
we got this laser power history,
and then we implement the into
RP. So, you can see ABCD you
know, depends on where you are,
you have different thermal
history, and remember, we want
that thermal history. So, we
basically shifted, so, this
product is because each point
you have a different birth time.
So, we shifted and compare for
example, the thermal history
that we want the dashed lines
are the constant laser power and
this solid lines are the why
using our computed laser power.
So, this is promising and then
the other thing that I mentioned
it was interesting is remember I
talked about the second time
period was using important
temperature reaching is
important. So, for this one,
basically, after each
simulation, you can accumulate
calculate accumulate time, and
go through the same exercise and
this is you know, computed from
the average point of view and
this is our experiments to also
you know, looking at the time
spent there. So, the bottom line
is, it is showing the
advantages, but I think there's
still more work that needs to be
can be done to further optimize
the optimization tool, as well
as the computational the power.
So, with that, you and I talked
about the process design, and
then the next point is about the
process modeling. As I
mentioned, earlier process
modeling needs to be fast enough
to feed into this process design
and one thing with the additive
manufacturing certain is the
microstructure prediction. So,
if you look at the powder bed
looking at the microstructure
and typically the best way you
know, the absolute The best way
is people use a face field
method to predict the the
microstructure and phase field
simulation is pretty expensive.
So, the question is typically
people looking at just around
the micro slice might feel
micron by few microns, and could
already cost quite a lot. So,
the question is, how do we speed
up this you know, because we we
build a very large part and the
male pool size is you know, 200
microns sometimes could be even
bigger, right? So, the way that
we do this, this is one example
looking at the physics embedded
graph network, so it is inspired
by the graph network, but it's
not using data training, okay.
So, what you can see here is
this is the seed grams and what
we do is for each grant original
grant it treated as a node. So,
for the node we have the
information such as temperature,
ground orientation and ground
volume, and then for the edge is
where the physics happening
right. So for the edge is
actually we are solving the Arun
k equations to to look at, you
know, how that will actually
calculate the liquid side The
fractures also control the brain
growth. So that physics pay a
fixed physics is calculated
around the edge, but what it
does is build up the graph
network. And to do this
calculation, so it's kind of
reduced order modeling approach,
and then you calculate the free
energy and then minimize that.
So, by doing this, you know,
this is a comparison between the
PGM model versus the DNS. And as
I mentioned, this is kind of the
reduced order models, so you
have less degree of freedom. And
the good thing is, you know,
it's it speed up quite a lot.
And because of this now,
firstly, you know, let's check
how it calculate how it works,
right. So, you compare for
example, the direct numerical
simulation versus the red Why is
a PGn and this one you compare
you know, the gram volumes are
pretty close, as well as an
aspect ratio coming up from
these two different methods. And
this is you know, reasonably
well, and because we can do
this, now, you can actually
model a larger model right,
because the computation is very
efficient. So, now you can
calculate a larger Vanya and
then you can monitor kind of
simulate multilayers So, what
you do is you use a previous
calculation as a result as a
seat for the next layer.
And with that, we can now
simulate for example, this is
two millimeter by two millimeter
one millimeter simulations. And
really, you know, interesting,
you can see these grand girls,
which is actually what also
people find out in their
simulation. So, the idea is, if
you have these grands, then you
can use also crystal plasticity
to calculate to the mechanical
properties, right. And so, in
the crystal plasticity piece,
you know, I don't have time to
talk about here, but you can
also think about once you have
the crystal plasticity, they're
still pretty expensive
calculated, and then you capture
how do you capture the
plasticity behavior also more
efficiently. So, the way that we
do it is this was back to 29 T,
and we use the numerical
simulation to to generate lots
of data. So here you know,
because we know the material
behavior is also a strength pass
and low pass dependency, right.
So, using the design of the
element of proach, you can you
can generate for this particular
one, we use 10,000 different
samples generated and then using
the Deep Learning Network,
basically, for that time, you
know, we have the fully
connected convolution neural
network as well as the LSDM. And
what's new here that
architectural wise, we also
incorporate the initial
microstructure into this
representation into this deep
neural network such that it has
a good you know, initial physics
and because of this, you know,
you can see the difference
between finite element
calculated which are the
discrete point about the yield
locus, as well as purely neural
network based calculated as a
solid ones. And they match
pretty well and particularly, it
could actually also capture the
evolution of the network, which
numerically if you do that, it
could be very expensive. So,
overall, you know, right now, we
are actually trying to develop
the whole package. This, the
code is at GitHub. So if you
scan it, you can you can find
it. So the idea is, you know,
for Jax am, you can use this one
to simulate using the Jets, you
know, the library as I mentioned
earlier, to separate the thermal
fluids and with the heat input
with a heat input, you can also
you know, simulate the local
grandgirls and with the
grandgirls use hand simulate to
the crystal plasticity. And then
also we have an FTM version,
which you can do the topology
optimization, so that I that
ultimately once it's fully build
up You can have location
specific material properties
coming from the additive, and do
the whole, you know, code
design, as I mentioned earlier.
So, this is a long term goal.
And we're coming, you know,
closer and closer, which I think
is very promising. Finally, I
want to talk about process
control. And so for a process
control, one key part is also
sensing. And in my lab, we have
about 40%, numerical, numerical
computation of people. And maybe
60% are experiment, experimental
lists, and some of the students
actually because they're
covering both areas. But the
point is, you know, for
experimental implementation, we
also need that sensing data. So
what we do for this one is, we
use the photo dye system, and
which was originally provided by
sigma labs. But what we did is
we have these photo dices and
lab with our laser laser path.
And this is, I believe, the
first implementation for the DD
system, and use two different
wavelengths, you know,
Calculate, calculate to the
relevant temperature. And, and
then it's interesting that you
can see this is the measurement.
And if you take the second
derivative of this temperature
measurement, you can actually
corresponding to find the
liquidus and solidus
temperature. So this is what we
find that the Deshaies and
liquids is temperature for this
Inconel 780. If you look at the
literature, there's a large
range of the air of various
people reported. That's not a
surprise, because a little
composition change, but changing
our liquidus and solidus
temperature. But the key point
is now we can actually institchu
measure that. And then when we
measure the cooling rate, if you
have lower cooling rate, this,
you know, match with the
existing hardware measurement,
which is great. And also for
high current rate, this one, we
have a sampling rate could be up
to 200 kilohertz. So for this
one, we can actually measure a
high cooling rate that the
others were saturated and won't
be able to measure. So, you
know, I talked a lot about the
DD, but we also have the high
resolution sensors to implement
for the powder bed. And the idea
is, can we use this as a tool,
such that we can do in situ
closed loop control. So in order
to do the closed loop control,
first thing that we need to
figure it out, is make sure the
data is not too noisy, because
otherwise you're going to get
something undesired. If you look
at the real time measurement,
this is a different layer
Assembly about actually this is
following the laser path, you
know, so the resolution claims
could be about 10 micron by 10
micron. So the idea is, if you
just put everything together as
a lot of data in 50 Gig get by
data just for this build. So
what we did is we use machine
learning based or to predict the
map or temperature of the next
layer based on the previous
layer. So the the key message I
want to this is also using the
random forest method, the key
message I want to come across
here is that, that this
definition of the features also
involve the physics
understanding about what's
important. So when we put these
things together, it gives us a
good prediction. As you can see,
here, you know, the prediction
is almost you can think about it
as a future. And with that, you
know, the noise are gone. But
also it's do capture some of the
fundamental physics right here.
For example, this one as the
laser turned around, you can see
that you know, first part is
lower and then you can actually
because it's a right turn around
the temperature increase. How
much time do I have? Well, you
have a 10 to 15 minutes. Okay.
Okay, that's good. So, for for
process control. One thing is
really important is actually we
have lots of different data
Coming together. So data fishing
or data alignment is important
for it. So for this one, we have
the machine level control, as
well as the CT scan, post CT
scan as well as the in situ
data. So, we put all these
together, you can then you can
see where the porosity are, and
that will help to guide the the
process design. So, it was also
interesting recently, we had
this sensor array sigma lab
system, as I mentioned earlier,
put together with the, with the,
you know, we went to the Argonne
National Lab, and instinctually,
you look from the top of the
sigma lab system, as well as X
ray, which is a projection to
the percussion about what's
happening. So you can see that
this is kind of we treated the X
ray as a ground truth. And you
can see this one laser is moving
around, and here is the bell
pool. And as you go around, you
can also see sometimes it
leaves, you know, porosity,
right? So, the key thing, what
we are looking for is we use
this as a ground choose, but the
question is, can we use the X
ray set, you know, the the top
view and using this, this set of
experiments to train our model
such that you can just use the
sensor array to detect what's
happening in in the, underneath
this right, which you cannot see
that from the top, but you can
only see it with the X ray. So
with this goal, we this, these
are some details I just skip. So
we took lots of data. And so
first part is a notation of the
male pool. And then, which takes
a long time, you know, one
minute per image, and we have
250,000 images. So this is a
perfect occasion to use, you
know, deep learning to help us
annotate the MailPoet. So that's
the first step. And then some of
the other things, you know,
which is not realistic coming
from the prediction, we have to
remove that based on
understanding about the physics
after it's done. And then we
tried to corroborate the the
MailPoet depths, as well as the
top signal, right, coming,
coming up. So I should change
this, this is already accepted.
So the point is, yeah, it's just
recently accepted again, just a
day ago. So the point I want to
say this is actually from the
top X ray photodiode system, you
can see those peaks. And what's
interesting with those peaks is
also corresponding to the
MailPoet, their ups collection.
So, you know, many times when we
think about this, you know,
whether this is a noise or it's
really happening, it actually
it's actually have some kind of
physics involved right there.
But the other thing, which is
interesting is, you know, you
see additional peaks right here,
which doesn't corresponding to
the MailPoet depth collapse. And
what's happening right here is
actually their son geometric
dependency. So the conclusion
that we got from this set of the
experiment is that it cannot be
just to the signal, it's
actually you need to consider
what geometry are building. So
the geometry factor has to take
into account to whether it's
overhand or just to you know,
solid base. So that's, that's
interesting. And the other one,
you know, there's a little peek
right here, but you don't see
anything here. The geometry here
is actually very similar to
here. What happened is, is a
sample rate of this one is 200
kilohertz hertz, and this one is
just 50 kilohertz. So I think
what we did is we pick up
something that was kind of
missed by the other other tool.
So you know, lots of data and
inaccurately look forward for
the car. elaborations to analyze
those data together. So I want
to just kind of finishing up by
saying, you know, physics based
and data driven was has lots of
future for us to look at this
qualification, right. So when we
look at the upside, you know,
the sensing data from the top,
we can pick up those things that
you won't even see with the with
the with a detailed X ray
because of the sampling rate. So
maybe we can use those data for
combined with a simulation, we
can do a qualification as we
built. So the other part, which
I'm going to finish up really
quickly, the other process that
we do in our lab, for the
flexible manufacturing process
is called double sided
incremental for me. So for this
one, you know, we actually build
our own machine as well. And
instead of using tooling we use
to, you know, as I mentioned,
the two tools, geometric
independent tools to move around
CNC control, and you can make
very different parts, the
challenging for the thing here
is because of the deformation is
all local. So to numerical
simulate this, maybe if I take
30 minutes to build it,
numerical simulation to simulate
very well, it will, could be
easily two weeks. So similar
challenge in terms of how can we
speed it up. And in application
of this process is actually, you
know, much faster and cheaper to
do it, you know, with the
various low volume production.
So company has already been
picking it this up. This is
Nissan picking it up. And here
in the States, you know, there's
a Makino labs, also picking up
you know, you can see all these
different parts build within a
week. And for legacy part, which
is particularly challenging, if
you have a legacy part, there's
no tooling, no drawing
available. And using this one,
you can actually speed up with a
week. But traditionally, you can
actually take a year or more to
get this part. So lots of
control also going out, you can
do the offline control to do the
inline control to get the
geometry right. So overall, you
know, recently, we are also part
of the ERC Engineering Research
Center we call hammer, which is
hype, hybrid autonomous
manufacturing, moving from
evolution to revolution. So the
idea is you can think about all
these flexible manufacturing
tools as toolbox, and you can
build other parts depends on
what kind of microstructure what
kind of material properties you
need. So the key thing behind
this is what I presented early
looking at, you know, some of
those future directions like
mechanics, mechanistic AI, to
determine physics needed. And
uncertainty quantification is
important. I haven't talked too
much about this, but we have
collaborated working on this
reinforced learning is
interesting, because then we can
also as well as transfer
learning to get to different
materials. We can use this for
process innovation for
simulation tools, as well as
sometimes you know, the human
machine to actions. For example,
the incremental for me, and
sometimes English. Well, in the
other process, you have human
involved as well. But the other
thing, I think a very, very
critical is also bridges,
designers and manufacturers, we
need the database. We need the
automatic manufacturing process,
plan generation. We also call it
functional metrology basically
qualification as you build. So
lots of interesting, you know,
areas to go for. And I would
like to acknowledge a group, for
sure without them, we can do it
as well as our sponsors with the
federal as well as a private,
sir, thank you very much.
Thank you. Thank you so much for
the wonderful talk. You know,
it's very nice. A lot. A lot of
things are going on here. I can
see that. Yeah, it was. You're
really actively working on
wonderful stuff. Okay. Let's
have a q&a session. And anyone
has a questions. You can unmute
yourself and ask questions and
answer
the question for your key case
one. Oh, first of all, thanks
for the great talk. Yeah, the
case you're case one, you have
the neural network connected to
a differentiable simulation. And
then you calculate the loss. And
then update. Do you also update?
Like both updates in the neural
network and the simulation? Or
you just Okay, how did you
update the simulation?
So the simulation, the
simulation is a physics space
dissemination, right? So the
neural network is really
representing the process
parameter. So we actually run
the physics bases simulation at
each iteration. The difference
is a physics based simulation.
In the even in the for analysis,
your gradient calculation is
done automatically by, you know,
jacks or tai chi. So, so when
you do the add them on top of
that, we have Adam, we use Adam.
And basically you use that just
to update the process parameter.
Does that make sense to you?
I see. And also, like, Are there
any cases in like, the model
will like the interactions
between the updates of the
weights in the neural network?
And also like the simulation
framework? Are there like some
trade off for like, some
interactions between these two?
Yes. So if you notice, you know,
the first time when we tried to
do? Yes, I tried it. Let me go
to the slide. I don't know which
one, let me just if you there
are too many slides. Sorry.
Okay, close enough, I think.
Right. So one thing you notice,
for example, in case one, the
laser power, you see that
there's actually have lots of
ups and downs, right, the change
of the frequency is much more
than the case two, for example,
this is a very, very gentle
change. And part of this is
because this trade off, as you
mentioned, I see. Right? Well,
thank you really relate to Ching
Hai question in order to, you
know, utilize both, you know,
simulation code and the neural
net. At the same time, the
simulation codes must be pretty
fast. But it needs to be fast.
And you have to trade off the
fidelity, like the accuracy of
the simulations. How do you
account for that? I guess,
higher tolerance, it's okay to
have the high
error. Yeah. So, this is as I
mentioned, this is something
that even back there. For me, I
think I have a slide to show
this, yeah, this one is this,
this was our kind of, you know,
we use a simulation and and
basically, you can see the
simulation experiments, right.
You know, so, it requires
calibration for some of those
parameters to kind of give us
some confidence that we can use
it, you know, and certainly we
are now modeling, for example,
the detailed about the like
mechanism, like rhenium flow in
the, in the simulation in the
experiments. So we are losing
some of those physics for sure.
And that's why in the current
development, I think I have,
sorry, try to get to that. Yeah.
So for example, in the current
simulation, right. So in further
differentiable simulation I
showed earlier was just for
using this path level, but the
path level, let's say, the
temperature input, it's very
much like just a gas in
temperature to represent the
beam, Laser Vein, but little
detail that like, what you see
the particle interactions, you
know, with MailPoet, we didn't
capture that. So the goal that
we want to develop at this level
is to use this as the input to
that one, you know, and so the
PATA level could be still
computational efficiency for the
design, but nevertheless, it's
going to be more accurate with
more physics involved and
Okay, so more feature work is
required. Yeah, yeah,
definitely. Okay. Kevin, you
want to unmute? Hi,
um, thank you for the talk. It
was very impressive to me. I
also have a question about
optimization about differential
with simulation compared to
urine network. And though, what
are the example of those are
trainable variable of the neural
network? I guess, I can see.
When you're trying to backprop
Okay, in front of physics based
simulation, you get the optimal
laser power. Right? And I guess
there is some other like, is
this sort of related to how to
control that laser power? Or?
Yeah, so for this particular
one, we just control, we
actually, we can control the
laser power depends on, you
know, your experimental setup,
we can also control for example,
in our experiment, we can also
control the base plate
temperature. So that's another
one you can put in there. I
think also, you know, in one of
our undergraduate projects, we
also develop the cooling nozzle
from the side. So if we
incorporate that, we can also
have the site cooling nozzle
locally as another control
variable. So I think, what
variable to control, it's not
that much limit in terms of the
numerical tour, rather than
experimental slide, you know,
where you can control how faster
you can control?
I see. So I guess, his neural
network, kind of like replacing
those physics part, like,
instead of like, implementing
all those physics part in the
physics based simulation, I
guess, is some parties with
replaced by the neural network.
Correct? Okay. Right.
Yeah. So reason we do that, you
know, you don't have to do this,
you know, I think you can also
just using the read, you can
also use maybe just as some kind
of simple function to represent
that. The reason that we do that
is really just because it's
pretty much in the same
framework with the
differentiable simulation. So
you can use that, you know,
integration wise, very
seamlessly, right. So this is
basically your trainable
variables? And then you can,
it's kind of interpret
interpreter from here to here.
And, and you can easily expand
that, and depends on what kind
of, you know, physical
parameters you can control?
I see. Thank you so much. It was
a very great talk. Thank you.
Is there any other question you
can unmute yourself and ask?
Well, I was really impressed. I
mean, you're able to do the
multi layer, and then, you know,
analyze the previous temperature
layer, and then use that for the
next layer. And usually, we try
to do that as well. But because
of the, you know, the
computational cost of the high
fidelity model we have here is a
lot slower than the model you
have. It's, it's kind of
bottleneck there.
Yeah. So for this particular
one, this is measurement. These
are the measurement and not the
computational. So
are you trained a neural net?
That's right.
Yeah, we trained it becomes
really fast. So the key thing we
actually have a recent paper
just accepted on this is what we
learned is that to give you
better prediction, you also need
to have the previous almost the
previous 2030, layers, data or
together to use to predict the
next one, because for this one,
it's easy in the sense that it's
only very simple geometry. So
the recent paper, we actually
look at all these different
geometries. And you can see that
the neighborhood as well as the
previous build up, a very
important so we actually we show
that we need the previous 20
layers or sometimes even
sometimes even 50 layers in
order to give us a good
prediction for the next Just
there. In I think the
computational time is doable in
the way to think about the
recording, you know, the
recording will take time. So
it's very much doable for that
timeframe. So it's not going to
be really useful if you want to
do following laser point wise.
So still layer layer level
control, not laser point and
laser pest control.
Right, right. Right. Yeah. Yeah.
Sounds good. I think we can
learn a lot from you. On the 3d
printing and the process
optimization. Is there any other
question from audience? While
you cannot let's,
yeah, yeah. Feel free to send me
email, you know, and love to,
you know, have some further
conversations.
Yeah. You know, hopefully we're
gonna have more collaboration
with you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you very much for this
great talk.